[Musique]
avec les confinements successifs qui
traîne depuis plus d'un an maintenant et
la grande sédentarité dia ces réformes
nous avons tous tendance à prendre du
poids en moyenne les français ont pris
2,5 kg
difficile aussi de se motiver à en
perdre avec une vie sociale de plus en
plus pauvre des horaires de couvre-feu
qui nous oblige à rester enfermé chez
soi et des salles de sport fermé depuis
maintenant des mois un confinement ça
nous a protégé du virus mais le
confinement n'est pas bon pour la santé
pourtant l'été arrive et avec lui
l'espoir de s'exhiber de nouveau sur la
plage ou au bord d'une piscine
mais alors comment faire pour perdre les
kilos accumulés quels sont les régimes
qui fonctionne vraiment et quels sont
les aliments à éviter de toute urgence
de nutritionnelle jean michel cohen est
avec nous ce soir pour nous donner
toutes les astuces pour perdre du poids
et rester en bonne santé
[Musique]
c'est expliqué qu'il ya une stratégie
dans un amaigrissement s'était tu vas
commencer avec un régime il peut être
très dur ou plutôt facile et derrière
pendant la durée de l'amaigrissement il
va falloir changer de régime en
permanence parce que tout le monde sait
quand on commence à maigrir avec un
régime au bout d'un moment ça s'arrête
et c'est quand ça s'arrête que les gens
ils stressent et quand il serait s'il
arrête tout et donc il faut changer
régulièrement de régime donc il faut
proposer des palettes de régime
castany vous changer régulièrement de
fabs et de régime mais toujours dans
comme j'aime par contre comme viennent
c'est toujours comme j'aime 1 bat
forcément avec l'oseille qui lui dit je
veux dire bah oui bah pour moi il peut
il peut le faire hein comme j'aime pas
est-ce que alors donc la technique c'est
vrai que j'avais géré penser parce qu'au
départ on seront tous contre on perd
beaucoup de poids au début mais qu'à un
moment on stagne et après une fois que
tu stack tunis ayeni com ou que c'est
quoi les remèdes mois les granola là
c'est vrai je connais bah voilà et donc
est donc tu repars et tueur grossit
encore plus tu dois encore plus gros que
ce que c'était avant
c'est exactement ça alors c'est pour ça
que par moment il faut faire des
séquences un peu plus agressive de
régime c'est ça alors il ya des régimes
difficile par exemple j'avais mis dans
le livre le régime à base d'oeuf et donc
on arrive à faire perdre 3 4 kilos en
une semaine à quelqu'un savall leur
motivé c'est pas le régime qui est le
plus intéressant mais ça va re motiver
ses amis le régime à base de fer on va
manger le matin on va faire une omelette
avec un seul jaune et 3 blancs donc ça
va faire une vraie fausse omelette on va
recommencer le midi et le soir on va
prendre des bouillons de légumes du jus
de citron ça va finir par couper
l'appétit ont fait pas durer ça trop
longtemps et derrière le matin et après
on fait quoi
j'ai bien mangé une omelette le matin
mais le régime à base de ckoi selongey
noblet et après tu fermes ta gueule tu
vas alarmant chez moi le midi le midi tu
vas manger la même chose la même
enveloppe pas la même
tu vas l'agrémenter différemment tu va
rajouter des légumes tu vas mettre
probablement yaourt en plus et tu vas
faire la même chose de troisième lot il
y a deux avantages
quand un régime est très monotone ça te
coupent l'appétit et quand tu manges
beaucoup de produits rassasiant comme ça
forcément tu as moins fin et après tu
peut redémarrer ton régime sur une base
beaucoup plus sympas et utiliser des
régimes très agréable dans lesquels on
peut jouer avec eux remplacés du fromage
par un bout de chocolat pour les
amateurs de sucré fait je vais remplacer
le caprice des dieux par un morceau de
côte-d'or ahmed - gac la non mais
sérieux là je parle je parle justement à
guillaume que c'est pas interdit
j'ai pris 15 kilos tmx n'ait pas fait
pas remarquer si le premier confinement
a pris 15 kilos pour environ 15 kilos je
mangeais remplacer le manger un litre et
demi de glace par jour j'étais tellement
déprimé remplacer un repas par exemple
par un burger s'est pas complètement
interdite le problème c'est qu'on va
organiser le beurre moi c'est que je
remplace tous les repas pardon tu peux
il ya une expérience qui a été fait
comme ça aux états unis où le garde
manger 1800 calories de façon mal
organisée avec de la malbouffe et ses
1200 calories avec un régime très très
sain et en fait il avait perdu
exactement la même quantité poids sauf
que ces analyses n'était pas pareil mais
manger un burger une fois par semaine
c'est absolument pas interdit
déjà c'est absolument pas les spaghettis
les spaghettis s'est autorisé alors
petit saute alors c'est quoi le régime
flash alors le régime flash c'est un
régime intermédiaire ça veut dire quand
les gens arrêtent de maigrir au bout
d'un moment on va mettre deux jours d'un
régime est un peu plus dur le matin on
va manger ou à boire un thé
on va prendre un fromage blanc le
million à manger une viande grillée avec
des légumes un yaourt et un fruit et en
fin de journée le soir là suicide c'est
ça les gens non mais arrête et donc le
soir on fait quoi on maigrit
ça veut dire que quand tu veux maigrir
de toute façon il n'ya pas ça arrêtez de
croire au régime irak maigrir c'est
diminuer la valeur calorique de son
alimentation gels
j'ai une question de gisèle bijaoui
est-ce qu'on peut manger des boulettes
d'être amore débat d'hathaway les bana
tâche pour ceux qui savent pas si des
boulettes spéciales tunisiennes a eu
beaucoup de pommes de terre
man est un peu de viande à l'intérieur
tunisien m pas beaucoup de viande parce
que je sais pas tu vas nous dire
pourquoi les algériens se remettre plus
et font savoir les noms mais jean-michel
donc le régime flash c'est quoi c'est
plus dur c'est un lien plus dur mais on
va le faire pour que deux jours par
semaine quand ça s'arrête de ménage sont
venus vers moi j'ai envie de perdre 10
kilos
ici non mais toi je suis donné un régime
spécial et 6 juillet c'est ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse très simple juillet il nous
reste avril à moitié du mois d'avril mai
juin
on va faire un régime modéré le matin
j'ai donné un morceau de pain alors
c'est toi qui vas me donner
[Rires]
d'accord le soir tu existes al adha une
viande
tu as un plat de spaghettis si tu veux
ou tu as des gnocchis août à dury tu
finis avec un bout de bois grèce a
instruit et le midi je te donne par les
sites appeltans danger quand comment
travaillent les coudes et on le fait en
sauce on est moins violente à mai mois
de valence non pas ça shaybah est une
vraie balle au bond voilà oui alors que
jean michel veron le fait ouais et
chaque semaine tu reviens ouais on
démarre lundi et le régime ça démarre
toujours là tiens ça va d'accord
d'accord c'est fait tu te dis d'accord
je fais je fais le bouquin je te
d'accord avec toi papa lé là mais le
régime celui que j'ai appelés quand en
plus on va le prendre tous les deux on
va le faire quoi ils ont créé tfc bull
il est plus parce qu'il ya plus à manger
que dans les autres non jure le coin de
plus il va perdre mais moi à kuan plus
tu mets un billet d'hier à bijoux
est une merde à lévis plus sérieux on
accompagne les chercher une balance je
vais me poser comme ça et j'aurai la
même tenue mais comme ça à noter la
tenue je te prie assurant garder voilà
alex on ne guérit les malades non mais
la balance il a pas trouvé vendredi à
valence alors je vais me poser je veux
exactement inverse la même que de les
micros les comme ça qui va les micros
les trucs par contre johnny les micros
ce sera les mêmes
jean michel cohen et avec lui ah ouais
quand même très savoir combien
conviendra 1,4 et fou quoi là tout
habillé je suis combien tu peux lire 87
5 87 mètre 98 là tu dois arriver
isabelle qui même à dire bien des
vêtements bizarres gérer je sais que tu
aimes bien parfum kg de vêtements
moi j'ai pas non plus une armée vous non
non non non mais je fais autre chose
c'est trop donc je tombe à combien 67
non oui avant fin juillet en vérité mon
poids de forme ces 73 113 entre c'est
déjà 77 et après on voit ça à chaque
combat jamais par les gars mais tu as
raison parce que 77
voilà les habits douze frères 74 ont
conquis je te promets que je vais mettre
sur le fait à grammont le style entend
les menus du jour pour savoir ce qu'on a
mangé jallet on promet aux résines et on
le sent sur le cfai on à 87 combien 87,5
87,5 il faut que tu reviennes temps la
pression tu reviens ouais mais moi mais
moi on finit l'émission on me joins donc
la mi juin des gens voient qu'on l'ait
avril mais mai juin à l'est le moins
normalement si tu le fais bien tour a
perdu entre sept et huit kilos s'est
fait en deux mousses effet bien sûr
c'est jean michel cohen dont ils peuvent
perdre avec ce régime dont je parle un
homme il peut perdre s'il le fait très
sérieusement il peut perdre entre six et
huit kilos les attend sur moi et entre
capacité de monsieur le musclé pour plus
comme j'ai dit non mais c'est pas très
rapide
un homme un homme c'est plein de muscles
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une dépense
d'énergie qui est très importante
non mais c'est vrai il ya six ans
énergique et très importante avec des
régimes relativement modéré qui pourrait
juste stabili
une femme on arrive à les faire maigrir
rapidement